bonjour et bienvenue dans ce 7 8 d'été
dans cette émission spécial dédié aux
cultures urbaines nous évoquerons
l'univers du hip hop beatbox break dance
DJing quiit à bousculer les codes et les
représentations collective allez on
passe à cet art devenu incontournable le
graffiti pour cela j'ai rencontré PASC
leeur
à alors Pascal où est-ce qu'on se trouve
ici dans le Graf
Park donc lieu dédié à la peinture sur
mur à la bombe en général mais bah pas
obligatoirement c'est un peu le berceau
local du graffiti pendant des années et
des années on est venu peindre sur un
bout d'usine qui existe plus qui a été
détruit en fait et c'était notre point
de rendez-vous à tous donc tous les
weekends et puis voilà les mercredis on
était jeune on avait nos mercredis et et
et voilà on se retrouvait là pas
forcément pour peindre juste pour se
retrouver aussi pour peindre quand on
avait de quoi faire la peinture donc
c'est resté le le le lieu de rencontre
de tous les gens du du du secteur de
manthe en fait pour pour la peinture
alors on parle de peinture est-ce qu'on
peut préciser les différences entre tag
grap graffiti en vérité il y en a pas en
vérité il y en a pas c'est c'est une
erreur de penser ça qu'il y a des
différences entre ces pratiques
euh peut-être non le le sens premier en
fait parce que en français on va dire
graffiti ou tag donc tag c'est une
signature on va dire en américain on va
dire to write écrire donc writer writing
et cetera donc ça veut dire qu'en fait
on est que dans la représentation de la
lettre c'est ça le point commun après
les moyens que tu tu prends pour le
faire que ce soit juste une signature au
caillou au marqueur ou que tu prennes 10
bombes pour faire une couleur ça reste
la même chose ça ve dire c'est le dessin
de la lettre c'est dessiner de la lettre
en fait c'est ça après par
extension on va parler de fresque et
cetera tout ça le mot graffiti il est un
peu un peu généraliste mais si on prend
la définition classique du mot graffiti
c'est vraiment le gribouillage dans les
toilettees c'est ça donc c'est écrire
c'est le message message ou pas mais en
tout cas c'est le fait de de représenter
des lettres est-ce qu'il y a des
mouvance aujourd'hui il y a des codes
spécifiques est-ce qu'on peut parler de
d'une évolution d'une évolution
B en fait on est dans le domaine de la
ça rejoint un peu la la calligraphie
donc c'est sans fin qu'une recherche de
lettrre c'est infini on peut on peut pas
avoir fait le tour d'un a ou d'un B on
le refera toujours différemment et
cetera il y a des écoles ça c'est sûr
qu' y a des écoles il y a des écoles de
style qui se sont créé donc en fonction
de ça on peut arriver à avoir une
lecture à savoir un peu le parcours de
chacun c'est c'est un peu le travail
d'un graphologue c'estàut dire on va
d'après une écriture on va arriver à
connaître le car carère d'une personne
c'est un peu ça en
fait le tager tag pour les tagurs parce
que il sait qu'il va être décrypté
compris perçu on va avoir une énergie
une certaine énergie une certaine et
donc on est on est vraiment dans ce
domaine là donc c'est un truc c'est un
peu une recherche c'est toujours un peu
une recherche quoi et un moment tu a une
école particulière ouais on peut dire a
on peut dire on peut dire qu'il y a des
écoles
vraiment autour de Paris les banlieux
elles ont développé quelque chose qui
est pas ce qui ce ce que à Paris donc
c'est proche hein c'est cousin on peut
pas parler de de grosses différences
mais il y a des différences dans des
dans des dans des subtilités de l'être
dans des dans des petites graphie
particulière ici moi j'ai grandi ici on
il y a une certaine culture orientale et
ça se retrouve un peu dans dans dans
voilà dans dans un Graf après tout ça ça
reste dilué parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de médias donc tu peux tu peux
vraiment avoir accès à à des productions
à l'autre bout du monde en cliquant donc
du coup les influences visuelles elles
sont pas les mêmes que quand nous on a
commc commcé où on avait des magazines
imprimés et et pas les mêmes que les
gens d'avant qui eu n'avaient pas de
magazine imprimés et qui se contentaient
de wiir ou de se déplacer pour aller
voir donc la transmission elle a
vachement changé aujourd'hui les écoles
elles ont tendance à se fondre un peu
les unes dans les autres mais quand même
tu as tu as un un une origine qui est
palpable boulot si tu vois plusieurs
pièces de quelqu'un tu vas pouvoir juger
d'une influence et puisqu'on parle des
influences internationales dans le
graphe je vous propose de regarder ce
sujet sur le festival graffiti
ambiance à la 3è édition du festival
graffitisme sur 400 m car de mur les
Français CTOI cette année brésilien
sud-africain et sénégalais venus
partager leur vision du
gra ve dire éch dans notre langue
c'estre avec des gars etéchanger surcoup
de stoup manière de voir la le graffiti
et le développement du du monde donc là
on est là pour échanger
quoi à ses côtés Rasy de Johannesbourg
participe aussi à cette fresque géante
collaborative ce qu'il aiment dessiner
des personnages au visage très expressif
reproduit à partir de
modèles le but c'est tout en ayant une
cohérence globale d'avoir chacun quand
même son son son esprit et ses
caractéristiques personnelles de de
style ensuite on a des styles variés de
toute façon par la présence de gens qui
sont plus Paris avec des crew 1984 ave
des travaux prégraphiques et puis
d'autres personnes plus plus plus dans
la couleur d' plus dans dans le
laettrage d'A plus dans le dans les
personnages donc c'est vraiment varié ça
représente vraiment la palette du
graffiti la palette du graffiti on la
voit souvent dans la rue et dans les
gares mais le festival ilinois
ambitionne de dépasser les
apriori vous savez ça ça s'appelle l'art
du graffiti mais certaines personnes
pensent que c'est du vandalisme d'autres
que c'est de l'art et ce qu'on essaie de
faire ici c'est montrer que ça peut-être
quelque chose de fructueux et positif ça
peut-être une forme positive
d'art et quoi de mieux que ce lieu dédié
aux cultures urbaine construit il y a 4
ans sur une friche industrielle de la
zone d'activité de la Vau couleur par la
Communauté d'Agglomération de mentonl il
est ouvert 7 jours sur 7 24 he sur
24 c'est super çavoir aussi le graffiti
est en train de de prendre sa place
comme il faut comme il se doit parce
qu'au Sénégal c'est c'est le Sénégal
même qui est devenu notre par parce que
on partage et c'est important d'avoir
des choses comme ça partout ça doit se
multiplier en Afrique du Sud on peint
librement sur les murs dans la ville il
existe quelques spots comme ici mais on
a aucun problème avec la
loi pendant de jours les performances
d'artistes attirent des centaines
d'admirateurs au gra par même des
familles comme cette sudiste avec son
bébé de 2 mois je suis venue profiter
d'une journée en famille avec cette
belle journée on a décidé de de venir
découvrir un peu les grapeurs c'est
juste énorme ça ressource aussi de toute
façon de voir des très belles choses
comme ça ça donne l'envie de d'aller
plus loin de progresser de partager puis
de d'échanger des nouveaux styles aussi
c'est un peu comme quand on va dans une
bijouterie on regarde les bijoux quoi
ici du beau monde donc on vient admirer
les artistes quoi on est des petits
joueurs nous donc voilà one les
PR Pascal se trouve donc au gra par de
quel est l'importance ce type de
rencontre
festivalitis beaucoup ça c'est beaucoup
ça donc c'est vraiment l'occasion de
croiser des gens
essayer de de faire des choses en
commun et et transmettre aussi je pense
c'est important ça veut dire qu'un cadre
comme ça on aurait rêvé jeune moi je me
trouve privilégié aujourd'hui d'être
invité pour venir faire une peinture et
le fait qu'il y a des artistes
internationaux comme les
Sud-Africains est-ce que ça apporte une
influence particulière ça donne des
envies des inspirations c'est
c'està-dire le graffiteur en général le
Tiger c'est un peu un monomaniaque donc
c'est très difficile de le sortir de sa
bulle de son monde c'est très compliqué
on est voilà donc c'est très ouvert à
l'échange mais au final très solo dans
son final voilà parce que parce que
c'est quand même quelque chose qui qui
peut qui peut qui peut vite être
exigeant et cetera c'est assez long donc
bon
finalement est-ce que ça apporte ça
apporte sur la diversité de de de ce
qu'il y a sur les murs après est-ce que
ça change le boulot que moi je je viens
faire aujourd'hui je pense pas que
pensez-vous des artistes qui arrivent à
exposer leur art dans des musées
prestigieux moi je pense que c'est
vraiment pas nouveau aux États-Unis ils
ont vécu ça dans les années euh fin 70
début 80 il y a eu un gros gros buzz sur
New York et puis après en Europe autour
de ça ça c'est un peu essoufflé là ça
reprend donc c'est un petit peu l'espèce
de parent pauvre euh de l'art parce que
c'est un mouvement qu'ose pas s'affirmer
en tant que mouvement avec un manifeste
avec avec avec comme ça une volonté de
dire on est dans cette case là on n pas
dans cette case là et et puis c'est
comme ça voilà et c'est un peu les les
les les courants artistiques ils sont
nés comme ça le graffiti il échappe un
petit peu à ça c'est ça fait sa force et
ça fait sa sa faiblesse en même temps
c'est l'ambigué de la chose le graffiti
fait aujourd'hui partie du patrimoine
culturel au même titre que d'autres
choses comme on pourrait dire de ma
peinture qu' le cubiste ouais ok
pourquoi pas on voit des influences
cubistes ouis tout à fait et pourquoi
pas mais
donc je crois que c'est assez assez
peeux
comme comme comme comme comme média
enfin en tout cas comme comme art comme
c'est un art qui est assez poureux qui
est assez réceptif à à l'extérieur à
l'histoire de l'art c'est
aussi c'est libre aussi de de ces de ses
mouvances c'estàdire y a une certaine
liberté parce
que on peut on peut on peut vraiment
intégrer plein de choses souvent ça part
dans le pop mais je crois qu'
aujourd'hui il y a vraiment plein de
tendances vraiment très très différentes
làdedans et la famille arrête pas de
s'agrandir se diversifier de se
transformer les gens murissent
grandissent il y a un peu de tout on
peut pas empêcher des
des des mauvais tagur de faire du tag et
comme on peut pas empêcher des bons de
le faire donc bah voilà après faut faire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut souhaiter à la
grande famille du Graf qu'est-ce qu'on
peut
souhaiter en moi c'est c'est je
souhaiteris plus à des gens d'arriver à
à sentir cette liberté au moment de le
faire en fait au moment de l'acte au
moment o au moment où tu tagues où tu
t'appropries un espace c'est ce que tu
ressens à ce moment-l qui est fort et et
c'est ça qu'il faut souhaiter c'est de
de se dire qu'on est dans un monde où
ouais on peut on peut se permettre de
prendre des libertés comme ça et moi je
crois que c'est ça qui est bon qu c'est
c'est essentiellement le le geste encore
une fois et peut-être pas tout le temps
forcément le résultat qui doit être beau
ou pas beau et c'est très compqué de
juger ce qui est beau ce qui est pas
beau enfin voilà et pour finir alors un
petit geste peut-être artistique pour
TVfil ouais ben vas-y on va faire on va
faire un tag c'est
parti